البنيه التحتيه للطاقه الاوكرانيه في مرمى
الهجمات الروسيه تضررت محطات وتعطلت
فتغيرت خطتكيف لا خيار الا هنا الفحم
لتامين الطاقه فاستقلالها اليوم اكثر من
اولويه في جنوب شرق اوكرانيا وفي اعماق
الارض العمل يتواصل الاستخراج الفحم عمل
شاق لكنه ضروري لدعم المجهود الحربي من
جهه وتزويد المدنيين باحتياجاتهم من جهه
اخرى الدفء والكهرباء تراهن كييف على
مناجم فحم توفر الطاقه اللازمه لاطاله نفس
المقاومه ضد الهجمات الروسيه وقود الحرب
اذا لا ينتهي وتكلفه باهظه تجنيد في
الجبهه وعمال هنا هم قله النعم لكن راح
الحرب الدائره تحرق الكثير من الطاقه
والكل يدفع الثمن عاجلا او اجلا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قنات
نا على الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات